[Music]
are you guys
fans of hoverboards yeah not
particularly
future hoverboards i'm a fan of the back
to the future hoverboards no i'm talking
about the real life
hoverboard no nobody [ __ ] that
hoverboard the
i mean i wish i was able to use it
really well
you know i wish i was like one of those
pros like b troy he's really good at it
he can just fly around the office and do
office things
he can go over cracks and bricks and
everything have you seen the one with
the fan
and uh die another day with pierce
brosnan's the last bond movie with
madonna in it as well what
donna's in it another day yeah she's
she's like his fencing instructor in the
movie
oh that's her that is her yeah yeah okay
yeah she was on a hoverboard no no
he's on a hoverboard he's fighting on
hoverboard in the beginning of the film
really yeah and north korea is supposed
to be yeah someone with the korean guy
that has blue eyes in it
no you're acting like i've seen these
movies i haven't okay
hoverboards um a lot of there were
huge craze right a few years ago a ton
of people wanted them
lots of people had them oh are they
filling landfills now or what
no yeah i hate the fact that they call
it a hoverboard
that's my biggest problem true if it
wasn't called that handle it's
fine with them just change the name it's
a wheel board bro
yeah wheel world it doesn't hover at all
wheelboard
i would think of a skateboard it was
called wheeled it's an one wheel segway
handleless segway yes that's what
but unfortunately they're called
hoverboards anyway
so back in 2016 this
dentist from alaska thought that it was
such a [ __ ] brilliant idea to do an
extraction on a patient
while he was on a hoverboard dude i'm
gonna show you
this video clip actually it sounds like
the videos where people like
lift really heavy weights on hoverboards
but this one is someone else's life
exactly here we go oh god oh my god
why he's on what exactly is this giving
you
on a [ __ ] hoverboard well can he do
it
then it's fine i i think that's great
okay i thought something bad was gonna
happen in the video
so cocky well why did he have himself
filmed
it's like he knew he wanted to just flex
yeah he did
because he ended up sending it to
multiple people outside of his
practice here yeah and he texted
new standard of care he sent it to at
least eight people
he just thought it was funny he goes huh
new standard of care
is that person knocked out or they know
he was on a [ __ ] knocked out dude
oh but did that person know that right
now i [ __ ] doubt
everyone ratted him out then a patient
named veronica
she testified against this yeah in court
and saying
what you did was outrageous narcissistic
and crazy yeah i was gonna say it's fine
if they signed off yeah
no she did and if i'm being honest cool
as hell [ __ ]
rad skills lame ass
skills yeah look i think i think he got
lucky that it was successful
yeah because if it didn't then he would
have been big [ __ ] julia he's been on a
hoverboard
many times before he brings it into his
practice okay
i read a little bit about this article
and didn't he get in trouble for some
other [ __ ] outside of like just this
though so he has been found guilty by a
judge
of 46 counts whoa they're saying
that uh he has his obviously his
his dental license suspended he's done
has been
found guilty he was convicted on 46
felony and misdemeanor counts
including medical assist including
medical assistance fraud scheme to
defraud illegal practice of dentistry
and reckless endangerment
that's a lot fully convicted on 46. how
many years that gets you
12. he's getting 12 years you think it
would be a little bit more
with 46. he's only 35 years old by the
way
46 lenient counts wait so if he never
did the hoverboard thing he wouldn't
have been caught for any of these things
no i think he was going down regardless
some of this stuff sounds like fraud too
so i'm sure someone was on his ass for
like auditing this [ __ ] and was like
we're gonna [ __ ] this because he was
billing medicaid for procedures that
were either unnecessary
or not properly justified so he'd be
sedating
people and charging them or charging the
insurance like
ten thousand dollars [ __ ] up yeah just
to sedate them
for no like so you could hoverboard
around them and [ __ ] be a dick yeah
exactly expect for the skills that [ __ ]
you
they could have like found out about all
the other stuff after the video came out
you know yeah
where they start like suing about that
and then they found out all the other
patients coming out and they're like hey
he did some kind of [ __ ] to me too
you know what i mean so wait what did he
[ __ ] up on this person
so this person was the fact that he was
on the hoverboard that's it but this
hoverboard incident is just like a small
piece of the bigger 36 counts i bet
recording her while she's asleep without
any kind of consent
that was another one was the fact that
he like this particular patient who
testified against him in court
she said i did not know that he was on a
[ __ ] hoverboard number one number two
i did not know that he was recording me
and if he would have asked me i would
have said absolutely no like
no no was he like do you understand the
science of hoverboards
yeah he was also found to perform
anesthesia thousands of times without
training or consent
on patients outside his scope of
training and expertise while stealing
money from medicaid and embezzling from
his bosses
so he has no training in anesthesia dude
that's [ __ ] scary
oh my god you're putting people to sleep
without training an extremely dangerous
job yeah that's why someone they have an
anesthesiologist that like trains just
for putting people to sleep like exactly
that's [ __ ] crazy you could die yeah
deja is like
so [ __ ] incredibly dangerous people
don't even understand how dangerous it
is how dangerous is it
it is so [ __ ] dangerous thank you
very much it is just so
how dangerous is it compared to getting
your tooth pulled out with the
hoverboard that's right
[ __ ] what
yeah but dude this is crazy like
like the [ __ ] balls the fact that he
texted this video to eight other people
and was like new standard of care
did he ever have a comment about it
other than that was he like
sick or anything i mean based on his
reaction at the end of the video
you know like yeah right i did it
yeah he did like a mic drop yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah i mean with that [ __ ] i i
definitely feel like it would be fine if
it was just like him and his bro
you want to make a video or whatever and
then they'd do that just like any other
blows who
post whatever weird crazy [ __ ] they do
on youtube yeah both you guys can sense
it to it
but the fact that she just like she
found out about it after imagine
imagine she found out because she got
like stabbed in the face whoa
see this now makes me hate the dentist
more even though he's just one dentist
out of the menu
because we just finished talking about
the dentist in another video today yeah
still don't like it
what if he just fell on her oh no
he's like my abs are [ __ ] rock hard
like i have my equilibrium
my core is like there's no way i would
have fallen
i can see him defending himself with no
lawyer or if his [ __ ] runs out of
batteries that happens too i've seen
that oh
what happens if it runs out of battery
so where a whole character
was on hoverboard the whole time and if
they run out of batteries they're [ __ ]
really it's just lunch it just stops and
they get [ __ ] yeah they go forward
that's crazy geez you got to keep that
[ __ ] yours
thinking about the hoverboard it reminds
me of isaac uh right in the hoverboard
isaac never mastered riding the
hoverboard with his feet
oh right i remember this yeah he would
go on his knees
and like his shins he would always land
like he'd be like this
and he would be like all right let's go
and that was so cute i missed that i'd
be able to lean forward like this and
lean back
he looks like a turtle yeah he mastered
it from
that position i remember coming into
work to like edit something and like
walk into the office and
i was like what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] who had that overboard
you're like james marshall in the sonic
movie
is going on around here there's a lot of
zooming around here
gotta go fast yeah that's so funny so
now prosecutors
are pushing for the court to order him
to pay more than two million dollars to
compensate for the funds
that he fraudulently uh obtained from
the alaska
medicaid system and embezzled is what
their
the department of laws is dating oh it's
alaska it's fine and they're so bored
out there
they get paid to live there they'll be
true
what city is this is like the major
cities yeah i was gonna say wait for
real they get paid to live in alaska
yeah but you have to like go to like
alaska well that was like a small
like like like an incentive not every
single person there oh
you get that old money there's like
settlements out there that are like
a little bit more remote than like a
major city yeah vermont kind of has that
too right
okay i have no idea vermont yeah because
so many people are you know leaving from
vermont too they have like big
incentives to go there and work there i
think you've got like
extra money or something do you get the
old money or money
from all oil is that what you're saying
oh oh
maybe like old money yeah like like gas
oil
so i was right get that all money
we have to decipher no sometimes no i
think i think he means both
old and oil old oil money
what did you say these people
what the [ __ ] are they saying casey help
me out here
i know you guys are bilingual but can we
like relax
thank you that's ridiculous
we've mostly in american audience guys
jesus true we have an english-speaking
audience
right okay that's freaking funny
the fact that you guys don't know this
they've these men have been taking shots
and everyone's slurring i
have also been drinking i feel like i'm
enunciating quite well
i just have wait who's our translator uh
julia is the only sober one shots for
julia
shut her down let's go julia
hey get the hat for julian
like the june beach get give her the hat
guys we all know what that means
what does that mean
[Music]
you